[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec sébastien
lyons alias pauvre diable bonjour
bonjour prirent alors vous habitez entre
les yvelines et le portugal vous venez
de sortir un morceau qui s'appelle terre
d'accueil on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
il fait pour
vous à ne comprends pas tous très bien
il a très faim c'est la seule chose qui
est claire il se glisse contre son père
lui attrape la main il a confiance papa
c'est toujours quoi faire
mais le grand monsieur le voit et se
moque il fait remonter tout le monde
dans le bâton mais pour être sûr qu'ils
ne reviennent pas de sitôt il met un
grand coup de pied dans la coque alors
ses morceaux raconte le trajet d'un
petit garçon syriens qui fuient la
guerre avec son papa pour trouver refuge
en france
pourquoi avoir fait un titre sur ce
thème là c'est vrai que c'est
c'est un sujet qui me touche beaucoup la
condition des bas des réfugiés ou des
gens qui essayent net réfugiés les
demandeurs d'asile c'est vraiment
quelque chose de ma famille ma belle
famille c'est ça fait longtemps qu'ils
reçoivent qui reçoivent des réfugiés et
moi j'ai toujours été très touché par
par ces gens là qui ont vraiment des
personnes et qui est qu'ils doivent
vraiment se battre juste pour avoir une
vie normale
mais ce qui me frappe souvent aussi
c'est que quand on en compte on en parle
dans l'est dans les médias c'est souvent
c'est souvent très déshumanisé souvent
des grossistes a fait peur c'est des
gens qu'on connaît pas qui font l'art
des différends qui parlent différemment
et en fait quand on les rencontre on se
sait c'est frappant à quel point c'est
les mêmes gens que nous qui ont la même
vie que nous et qui en fait on des
conditions horribles chez eux qu'ils
essayent de venir
enfin juste de vivre en paix dans un
autre pays il est je m'étais dit ok
peut-être que moi ma petite contribution
ce sera de dire ce sera de mettre un peu
en valeur l'aspect humain de ça et c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire dans la chanson
ou de décrire ce qui se passe vraiment
et je pense que il ya plein de gens
surtout à l'heure actuelle qui qui te
plaît un peu sur soirée c'est difficile
en tant que commis dont faire les
frontières on fait tout ça mais pour moi
c'était vraiment important de montrer
l'humanité de tous ces gens là et de
dire bah voila si on les rencontre si si
on a un peu plus de de compréhension de
ce qu'ils vivent et ben ça ça permet un
peu de voir le problème de façon
différente d'un clip aussi il ya des
visages
deux personnes qui ont fui et qui sont
demandeurs d'asile en france et ça voilà
exactement donc c'était pareil c'était
important pour moi de encore une fois de
faire un clip très réaliste le plus
humain possible et je voulais vraiment
voilà la plupart des clips c'est le
chanteur ou le groupe qui chante et pour
moi ce n'était pas ce n'était pas le but
de de montrer ça le but c'est de montrer
des vrais demandeurs d'asile et de
montrer leurs réalités dont j'ai
travaillé avec une association qui
s'appelle grs wacom qui est vraiment une
belle association qui aide les
demandeurs d'asile à réaliser leur
démarche en france ce qui était chose
d'extrêmement dur quand on suit le
parcours
c'est à dire qu'il ya tout là tu es en
vie combien la france accueille et c'est
qui voilà qui est très bien et puis en
fait en pratique c'est des choses du
style on appelle on passe cinq heures au
téléphone sans avoir de réponse on se
lève à 5 heures du matin on fait là on
fait la queue pour le pendant huit
heures pour ce faire fermer la porte ça
c'est des réalités des choses et donc
voilà donc ça c'est ce dont on aperçoit
contre avec les associations et donc eux
qui ont été vraiment adorable
on monte vraiment soutenu dans ce projet
et m'ont permis de voilà de contacter
tous ces demandeurs d'asile en leur
demandant bien sûr s'ils souhaitaient
partager leurs photos faire partie de ce
projet est donc moi je suis je suis ravi
parce que ça permet de mettre voilà des
photos de mettre en valeur des vrais
champions qui ont fait ce parcours là
donc c'est plus plus réaliste pour moi
que de l'équipe habituelle quoi alors
pauvre diable c'est votre nom de scène
il fait que votre parcours scolaire et
professionnel
est ce que vous nous en dire un peu plus
en tant qu arte c'est toujours très
difficile de se trouver un nom pour moi
cela il est quand même arrivé comme
comme une évidence et à dire que j'ai eu
un parcours scolaire aurait un peu un
peu difficile ou pour moi l'école je
n'arrivais pas vraiment à comprendre le
sens quand j'étais petit de d'apprendre
tous ces trucs là de rester assis huit
heures par jour et donc j'étais pas trop
investi dedans au point que je conserve
à pas mal de problèmes et
d'être voie la plus à l'est en cours
d'être un peu trop indisciplinés et donc
le terme pour rhodia bhl c'est lé prof
qui m'a pris un peu comme ça à l'époque
et puis un moment j'ai eu un gros
revirement où je me suis dit on fait
effectivement par contre ma vie elle
n'est pas dans le bon sens avec trop
haut trop de voilà trop d'erreurs de la
part et donc j'ai fini par me rendre
compte que je me rendais malheureux que
je rendais les gens autour de moi
malheureux et donc j'ai décidé de un peu
vraiment par dépit de dire bon bah je
sais vraiment pas quoi faire de ma vie
qu'est ce que je vais faire je vais
faire comme les autres j'ai un peu
travaillé à l'école jeu c'est d'avoir un
bon métier et c'est donc c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai fini par faire part
par travailler vraiment juste par dépit
quoi et parce que j'avais un autre
affaire et le j'ai beaucoup travaillé
après à l'école pour oublier un peu mais
mes questions existentielles je dirais
et
et je suis devenu je suis je suis devenu
un professionnel pour pour travailler
avoir un bon métier que ce terrain puis
au bout d'un moment assez récemment je
me suis regardé dans la glace en disant
mais ok je suis plus un pauvre diable au
sens de ce que mes profs 10 mai mais mon
regard sur moi même c'est moi qui m'a
évalué comme étant pour revenir parce
que c'était j'avais je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais une vie qui
correspondait pas du tout à ce que je
voulais faire
métro boulot dodo travail argent ex
terrain et donc je me suis dit c'est pas
possible quoi et donc je me suis dit
voilà donc lie à peu près de deux ans je
les ai tous quitté j'ai quitté mon job
quitté j'habitais à londres quitter
londres et puis j'ai déménagé au
portugal pour prononcer vraiment dans la
chanson est donc pour moi pour re diable
ça a été un peu ce seul ait motifs qui
m'a qui m'a poussé à faire ce changement
quoi ou est ce qu'on trouve la force
pour passer de traders si je me trouve
pas à londres à chanteur au portugal est
ce que c'est le fait de voir qu'on n'est
pas heureux dans sa vie en fait qui nous
pousse à partir ouais pour moi ça a été
mais je dirais que ça a été ça a été pas
mal ça où effectivement ouais je me
sentais bon effectivement j'étais trader
à londres mais voilà encore une fois
c'était quelque chose que j'avais fait
je sais pas si à qui que ce soit qui dit
à disant tiens mon rêve c'est d'être l
heure je pense je pense qu'il ya
personne donc moi ce n'est pas le mien
non plus mais effectivement au bout de
dix prix dans dans ce truc là où tout le
monde autour de soi dire passé jonathan
super métier tu as vraiment réussi dans
la vie extra donc s'est saisi de faits
de voix l'adav d'avoir d'avoir des
oeillères et de désir bon ben ok c'est
ça la vie quoi et il puis en fait non
effectivement un moment je me suis dit
non mais c'est pas possible que que ce
que je fais n'est vraiment à ce point là
aucun sens donc pour moi effectivement
ça a été le moteur je dirais même au
delà d'être malheureux je dirais que
c'est surtout le la sensation de se dire
bon ma cheville quand même est ce que je
fais n'a vraiment aucun sens pour moi
serge me lève et je gagne de l'argent
pour une entreprise qui on a déjà sans
de trop donc je me suis dit ok je sais
pas vraiment c'est quoi le sens de la
vie mais je sais que c'est pas ça donc
je vais c'est autre chose je veux aussi
la musique
donc ouais c'était un peu ça l'avait
l'impulsion dont il ya deux ans et ça
vous avez vous donc l'année dernière
vous avez sorti votre premier single le
1er mai 2020
il s'appelait hommage aux soignants les
soignants des réfugiés est ce qu'il ya
vraiment un côté engagé militant voire
politiques ou c'est simplement des
sujets qui vous toucher vous avez envie
de coucher sur papier c'est sûr que tous
les textes à son sont assez engagé c'est
ce qui me sort c'est à dire que en fait
avec l'écriture la culture ça c'est
marrant on fait donc moi j'ai découvert
pas mal l'écriture du coup récemment est
en fête avec les futurs moi mon
expérience c'est qu'en fait on ne
choisit pas vraiment quoi ce qui sort
c'est ce qui sort et donc c'est vrai que
moi c'est les voilà les sujets
d'actualité qui me touche je pense que
comme beaucoup de gens le le voilà les
soignants rapporte que vous avez des
soignants à la société au moment du coc
vide et en plus mon approche c'était
aussi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de soignants dans ma famille
donc c'est un sujet qui me touche pas
mal et en fait on on savait déjà depuis
des années que leurs conditions de
travail était absolument inacceptable et
moi quand je vous convie d'arrivée avec
le gouvernement qui avec voilà juste
avec un décret divin rendre là vous
allez bosser deux fois plus sans
augmentation salaire sans augmentation
de moyens nous sinon mais c'est pas
possible on était déjà on était déjà
largement largement à flux tendu c'est
pas possible de gérer ça donc
effectivement il ya ça qui est sorti
après j'ai mon hautement ceci ma fille
aînée qui vous dirait sans doute mais
sans doute à ses militants aussi au
final où pareil quand ma fille est née
voilà je pense que comme tout le monde
comme tout papa ya pas mal pas mal
d'émotions qui viennent et puis au final
j'ai couché ses émotions sur papier
c'est vrai que le texte qui vient d'une
certaine façon il à ses militants sur
sur la condition de la femme dans notre
dans notre société donc je suis pas
exactement comment on fait pour évoquer
sur mass effect ou le texte pour
l'instant sur la soie s'est engagé
j'essaie je pense que les prochains je
vais essayer de me forcer à faire
quelque chose peut-être plus léger je ne
sais pas mais wes herrett pour l'instant
c'est ce qu'ont déjà et beaucoup fait de
la musique et je dirais que ce qui je me
considère avant tout en écrivant au fait
c'est vraiment les mots pour moi donc
vraiment bon c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi le slam plutôt que je fais la
musique depuis longtemps mais c'est vrai
que j'avais vraiment envie de choisir un
genre où on est obligé d'écouter les
paroles c'est à dire que voilà avec la
plupart des musiques et on entend
beaucoup la performance contre beaucoup
beaucoup de chanteurs beaucoup les sons
etc
on n'a pas forcément besoin d'écouter
les paroles je trouve qu'avec le slam
que j'ai choisi au moins c'est clair si
vous voulez pas écouter les paroles vous
éteignez
donc nous a pour moi c'était vraiment
les paroles sur l'honneur donc je me
considère presque plus que comme un
écrivain comme un musicien
après ce dont je me suis rendu compte en
fait c'est que j'ai écrit quelques
quelques livres quelques quelques
quelques cours d'histoire et en fait
c'est voilà encore une fois moi ce que
je fais c'est des textes quand même
assez court avec une émotion précise
avec avec un message précis et j'ai
trouvé qu'on fait ça passait bien
rassurant sur un sur un morceau voilà
deux trois quatre minutes à ses impacts
entre est clair que que qui est plus
simple sans doute
pour véhiculer un message que un livre
complet donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi que j'ai choisi voilà la musique
et ce genre là à moi que je vous écoute
ça me fait penser à grand corps malade
est ce que c'est des personnes comme lui
qui vous influencent web roma l'a bien
sûr vous n'êtes pas le premier à me le
dire
grand corps malade oui bien sûr c'est
pour c'est vraiment géant de du genre
évidemment et puis là je pense qu'il a
enfin je reçois une sensibilité de sa
part qui est assez proche de la mienne
ses proches de ce qui me correspond donc
donc oui des gens comme ça des gens
comme grand corps malade abd al malik
des gens comme ça qui rayent qui met
vraiment texte à l'honneur qu'ils ont
vraiment un message à faire passer qui
sont engagés qui sont qui ont des choses
à dire ouais c'est vraiment des gens qui
m'influence et qu'il me dise enfin qui
me font dire au caire on peut c'est une
voix de deux pas de passer par voilà
partie par ce média là pour approuver tu
es un message
donc vous êtes auteur interprète qui
fait la mélodie puisqu'il ya même un
petit peu près tout à fait alors le
sueur sur ce morceau là c'est christophe
ena qui est un super super musicien qui
a travaillé avec moi j'essaye j'essaye
souvent de travailler avec avec d'autres
musiciens aussi mais il ya pas mal de
morceaux je pense que quand même la
plupart c'est moi qui les ai composées
aussi qui fait la musique derrière donc
moi je fais les choux et le piano donc
j'essaye voilà donc ça dépend donc
j'aime bien j'aime bien travailler avec
d'autres gens c'est assez différent
travailler tout seul davantage c'est que
ça va vite et le morceau il ressemble
exactement à ce que je veux me sera créé
avec d'autres musiciens il ya vraiment
quelque chose dans cette tension la de
travail à quelqu'un d'autre qui est du
coup c'est pas exactement ce que j'avais
en tête au début mais ça apporte
vraiment une dimension une dimension
autre et là par exemple christophe sueur
sur ce morceau là c'est j'aurais jamais
composer un truc comme ça et christophe
est vraiment très talentueux et je
trouve que ça ça met vraiment en valeur
la voix est encore une fois d'une façon
différente de ce que j'aurais fait donc
donc moi moi je suis je suis ravi du
résultat final question qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter pour la suite
ben je sais pas moi ce qui me plairait
c'est moi mon rêve c'est que voilà c'est
que mes chansons est là elle voit là
qu'elles sont un peu véhicules et
quelques avec qu'elle participe un petit
peu à éveiller les consciences sur ces
problèmes a qui sont pas forcément
encore une fois le sujet des réfugiés en
ce moment c'est pas super sexy parce
qu'on est plutôt en train de parler et
je comprends de se replier sur toi de
fermer les frontières mais si je peux
contribuer un tout petit peu à éveiller
les consciences sur ce sujet est ce que
les gens disent ok il faut se protéger
il faut penser à soi mais il n'y a pas
que ça dans la vie il ya aussi des gens
qui sont plus en difficulté que nous et
qui ont besoin d aide
et ben j'aurais gagné mon pari merci
beaucoup c'est bastien
je rappelle donc que l'intégralité du
des profits pardon du titre terre
d'accueil sera reversée à amnesty
international
c'est bien ça qui est parfait merci
beaucoup merci et merci à vous d'avoir
suivi cette émission se retrouve bientôt
dans un nouveau vip
[Musique]